Update on how shitty of a person Dave Grohl is.
Because here's the thing. He was known as the nicest guy in rock.
And he's had so many fucking,
like, picture opportunities with his kids to show what,
like, a great,
gentle guy he is. And what did he do?
Motherfucker was accusing his wife of flirting with her tennis coach
because he knew he was having a fucking affair.
They're not cliches. It's not, like,
made up. It's not women just trying to, like,
get in your head and steal your man.
Like, it's common sense.
If you feel it in your gut that your man is a piece of shit,
he's probably a fucking piece of shit.
When he's accusing you of shit that you haven't done,
and it starts to make you question.
Don't question yourself. Don't question yourself.
It doesn't matter if they're a fucking rich rock star
or your broke homosexual that's,
you know, started out sleeping on your couch.
You know the kind of man that your boyfriend is or your partner is.
And when you have those feelings,
listen to them.
Because there's no point in giving someone the benefit of the doubt,
because what are they gonna do?
They're gonna use it to fucking hurt you.
I cannot stand this man.